they're queuing around the clock now
around 40 000 people maybe more
it's a queue that's over four miles long
making sure that such a huge number of
people can all get to see the queen
lying in state is proving to be a huge
logistical effort there are now more
than a thousand stewards and volunteers
lining the route to make sure all of
this can be achieved safely
it's a case of eating and drinking on
the Move well I've got a vegetarian
sandwich oh nice I've eaten my
sandwiches already
I've eaten my sandwiches as well
and along the Route a reminder of big
Royal occasions of the past the events
of the last few days of course now part
of that history good to see you eating
we like that volunteers from St John
Ambulance Patrol the route I've helped
an elderly lady who was struggling on
her feet to come along and we gave her
some Paris seesaw for a bit of pain
relief to to keep her moving so whatever
the public needs her to get their first
aid from us we're here for it enjoy your
responses you come along thank you this
is the first time experience in such
queue never had it in the past three
years in security doing a lot of events
hundreds of events this queue has been
the longest and it's just keep on coming
you've got a sort of sustain yourself
haven't you've got a drink you've got to
eat that's it it's kind of a bit of a
mission this isn't it it is a mission
but there is a light at the end of the
tunnel
um and you know you just know that it's
going to be a magical moment in there so
let me have a look at this what is this
homemade it's a homemade hand side let's
have a look we want to see that is a
wonderful ham sandwich that was made at
seven o'clock this morning
one of the final legs of this queue
moves down the Albert embankment
past the hundreds of thousands of hearts
that Adorn the wall in memory of those
who died in the covid pandemic
Dara Leonard from the Red Cross has been
offering emotional support to those who
might need it at the core of
is is bereavement or grief
and then some of those conversations
as they're talking
they then disclose about the the death
of a loved one perhaps very recently and
perhaps as you say with the covered wall
down there they're standing looking at
it and it may have been someone that
that has passed away very very recently
and that's when we'll stop and we'll
spend a moment and there'll be many more
moments like that over the next three
days as they queue to see the queen Nick
Martin Sky News Central London